quoi qu'il est fonctionnel mais ça fait
François Cardin et propriétaire de cet
immeuble depuis 20 ans et quand on lui
demande si ses avertisseurs sont en bon
état
80%
cette vérification des avertisseurs une
brigade spéciale en été chargée tous les
étés depuis 12 ans à Montréal mais le
service incendie a décidé d'y mettre fin
nous sommes dans une référente complète
de notre programme de vérification
d'avertisseur de fumée de recrutement et
un taux de réponse trop faible de la
part des citoyens la brigade composée
principalement d'étudiants à vérifier
près de 300 000 logements depuis 2015 et
à la fourni plus de 35000 avertisseurs
de fumée au montréalé qui ont ouvert
leurs portes cette brigade était très
appréciée par les citoyens de Montréal
et c'était un autre élément de
prévention qu'on apprend aujourd'hui que
malheureusement était retiré selon
l'opposition le Sim aurait dû profiter
de la commission publique la semaine
dernière pour expliquer la disparition
de la brigade pour ce propriétaire
c'était une tranquillité d'esprit
concernant ces locataires
c'est ça donc la brigade la pertinence
de la brigade et là aussi pour toutes
les habitants de l'immeuble mais le
service incendie assure que sa nouvelle
stratégie lui permettra de faire plus de
vérification en responsabilisant les
propriétaires exemple les agents de
prévention n'iront plus frapper aux 24
portes d'un immeuble à logement en fin
de démarche auprès du propriétaire
immédiatement pour s'assurer que les 24
logements ont un avertisseur de fumée
ça fonctionne très bien une tâche qui
reviendra désormais entièrement aux
pompiers et aux préventionnistes ici
Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal